La saga de la station spatiale
internatis-ci les Russes
affirment qu'ils vont bientôt
e collaborer avec
les américains dans l'espace
et quitter en emportant,
qui sert à propulser la station.
La position des russes est
difficile à suivre. Il y a
à peine Dimitry Rogozine, le
belliqueux directeur de l'agence
russe, qui avait menacé
en mars dernier de mettre
un terme à la collaboration
Le même jour, le Kremlin
signait un accord avec la
pour permettre aux Russes de
continuer à voler sur des fusées
Une excellente nouvelle.
Mais la trève entre les deux
puissance courte
durée.
Les RussLes RussLes RussLes Ruse
concentrer sur la constructiond.
y avoir bientôt pas mal
de traffic dans la basse
atmosphère terrestre.
Selon la NASA, plusieurs
stations spatiales privées
la vieillissante Station
internationale, qui sera
détruite en 2030.
Et les Chinois viennent
tout juste d'agrandir
- It's an infortunate
developpment.
- De son coté, le département
d'Éta
avoir été pris par surprise par
la décision de Moscou de mettre
vieille d'une vingtaine
.
ICI Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, M